have you ever gotten stoned been blazed
not even a little contact hi whether you
smoke pot or not legalizing weed is an
issue the US government and other
countries increasingly can't ignore so
step out of your hotbox and come with us
on a little journey as we take a look at
the biggest arguments for and against
legalizing recreational marijuana almost
half of Americans have tried weed and
even more think it should be legal
especially celebrities like RiRi who
instagrammed herself smoking a fatty or
Matt Damon who once told the BBC about
the first time he ever got high which
was with his mom problem is they're not
the ones getting punished for breaking
the law it's young people and especially
people of color get this blacks and
whites smoke pot in roughly the same
numbers but blacks are almost four times
as likely to get arrested for possession
a single marijuana arrest can make it
harder to get a job financial aid or
even housing and who's fronting the bill
for all this police work targeting
possession Americans honest tax dollars
to the tune of 3.6 billion in 2010 alone
legalization would not only save
enforcement money but it could also make
consumption safer advocates say
regulating marijuana and taxing it is
better than having people consume stuff
illegally without even knowing what's in
it or where it came from another
argument to legalize tobacco and alcohol
are legal and so are prescription drugs
so why not Mary Jane there are no fatal
diseases clearly associated with weed
unlike tobacco or alcohol and you can't
overdose on marijuana
unlike legal prescription drugs which
are killing more Americans than heroin
and cocaine combined still legalization
opponents like the White House say
health risks especially for young people
are exactly why weed shouldn't be legal
they argue that brain development takes
a hit
literally some studies have associated
prolonged marijuana use at a young age
with cognitive impairment and lower IQ
opponents also warn that legalization
could lead to briefer men
but the jury's still out on that one one
study has already shown that in states
where medical marijuana is legal high
school students did not end up using it
more finally a big argument against
legal read is that stone drivers pose a
risk to everyone on the road and the
problem is you can't measure read
intoxication as effectively as alcohol
pot stays in your system for so long
that there's no way of telling if you
smoked an hour ago or a week ago so
those are the nuggets at the heart of
the legalization debate and even though
the White House is against it guess who
admitted to getting high when he was
younger when I was a kid I
I inhaled frequently that was that look
that was the point well you did pretty
well for himself besides that whole
hypocrisy thing but where do you stand
should America legalize recreational
weed tell us what you think and even if
you don't puff puff make sure to pass
along this video
you